good afternoon mr. president colleagues
friends families and most of all to you
the class of 2011 welcome and
congratulations on this day
baccalaureate it is customary for the
president to deliver a baccalaureate
address and for the Dean of Yale College
to offer a few readings so make
yourselves comfortable for some readings
I've chosen to share with you in your
daily travels at Yale you walk through
this building where we are today Woolsey
Hall on a regular basis some of you walk
through the Rotunda dozens of times a
week you think of this space is Commons
or the grand concert hall that surrounds
us now but what is this building it is a
war memorial and this is once again a
week just before Memorial Day when we
think of and honor those who have died
in their nation's service from lexington
massachusetts to afghanistan but more
Americans died in the Civil War than in
all the other wars in which US soldiers
have fought and died the names of Yale
soldiers Union and Confederate north and
south are inscribed just outside this
hall in his first inaugural address
delivered just a month before the war
began in 1861 a hundred and fifty years
ago the newly installed President
Abraham Lincoln told his audience we are
not enemies but friends we must not be
enemies though passion may have strained
it must not break our bonds of affection
the mystic chords of memory stretching
from every battlefield and Patriot grave
to every living heart and hearthstone
all over this broad land will yet swell
the chorus of the Union when touched
again
as surely they will be by the better
angels of our nature four years later
after 700,000 yes nearly three-quarters
of a million soldiers had died President
Lincoln closed his second inaugural
address in this way with malice toward
none with charity for all with firmness
in the right as God gives us to see the
right let us strive on to finish the
work we are in to bind up the nation's
wounds to care for him who shall have
borne the battle and for his widow and
his orphan to do all which may achieve
and cherish a just and lasting peace
among ourselves and with all nations a
just and lasting peace Yale students by
and large young men from New England
would have read those words in a local
newspaper perhaps reading the text aloud
to one another those students knew the
rent in the National fabric the broken
bones of the united states that had not
yet begun to knit together we continue
to strive for healing now nearly 150
years later in both national and
international respects Lincoln calls for
friendship in both these formal speeches
to his countrymen to care for him for
his widow his orphan friendship as the
150th anniversary of the war approached
the New York Times ran a series about
the short life of a foot soldier killed
at Gettysburg in 1863 and whose orphaned
children became symbols of the wars
sacrifice of the abandoned and wounded
who would need care and comfort and
friendship The Times has given the
fallen soldier a new life a story of
hardscrabble farming of wailing and
battle compellingly revealed in his
letters to his wife where one learns
that they were one another's best
friends in the short lines of his last
letter home
he found a way to express the depth of
his love for his friend if I ever live
to get home you will not complain of
being lonesome again or of sleeping cold
for I will lay as close to you as the
bark to a tree Amos Humiston days before
the Battle of Gettysburg you 2011 you
arrived here as strangers you leave his
friends many of you have been my own
friends it's been a great joy to know so
many of you as a professor I've known
you in the classroom and I know that
there are some members of my freshman
seminar from the fall of two thousand
seven who are sitting here today in my
days as a college master I've known many
more of you in the dining hall here's
what happens to you yell undergraduates
you change you acquire new knowledge
much of it useful some of it quirky you
learn how to ask better questions a
generation or two learn to do so through
children's encyclopedia known as The
Book of Knowledge who's black and
cracked spines sat on a shelf in my
family home the reading of long winters
and perhaps the it was the very edition
of 1936 from which the prose poem I'm
about to read is conceived stay with me
for 17 questions as I take you to from
the book of knowledge by Cynthia Zarin
who perhaps also taught some of you one
what makes a fairy ring very rings are
made of a kind of fungus to why does
damp air make us ill damp air is often
cold air and the cold has usually been
blamed for making us ill though many
facts prove that it is not blameworthy
at all three why does a dog go round and
round before it lies down the answer to
this question lies in another question
what is a talk for can our brains ever
fill up the poet browning says there is
no end to learning 5 why does a tuning
fork sound louder when it touches would
the sound from a tuning fork like the
light from a candle flows out in all
directions 6 why are some things
poisonous we could answer this question
completely and fully only if we knew all
there is to know about life 7 why can we
hear better when we shut our eyes this
question is partly true and partly not
true 8
aight can an animal think there's no
doubt an animal can think and that it
can remember 9 do animals feel pain as
we do that is not a question that can be
answered directly 10 why do we not growl
like animals when we are hungry a hungry
man is an angry man 11
11 why have leaves different shapes the
great idea which we learn to apply to
every fact about living creatures is
that these facts usually have uses 12
why did the leaves of the aspen always
shake the shaking of the leaves has the
same effect as if the trees were Fanning
themselves 13 why does oil make a wheel
go round more easily it all depends on
where the oil is put 14 why do we see
the stars only at night the stars are
shining all the time sending light to
earth but more than this is needed for
us to see 15 is an atom alive it is
almost a living thing 16 can country
people see writ small better than
townspeople if country folk use their
eyes mainly at distances their vision
will be keenest at distances 17 why does
a lump rise in my throat when I cry it
is the place of speech which is the most
marvelous thing finally it is a yale
college tradition at this point and on
this occasion to read a passage by John
Milton you know the story I think there
were these two young 20-somethings maybe
even teenagers and they were in a garden
they were in a perfect place and they
knew that and yet they also knew that
there was a world beyond and they
couldn't help but want to know about it
yes as in the Zarin poem there was a
thirst an unquenchable thirst for
knowledge and you remember there was
also that wardrobe malfunction part that
they had well
like you and as you may particularly
feel on Monday afternoon or tuesday
morning their departure seemed to them
sudden unwarranted abrupt and inevitable
from Paradise Lost by John Milton 1667
some natural tears they dropped but
wiped them soon the world was all before
them where to choose their place of rest
and Providence their guide they hand in
hand with wandering steps and slow
through Eden took their solitary way
congratulations class of 2011
good afternoon before I begin my remarks
I want to welcome the parents of our
graduates I know how very special this
weekend is for you my wife Jane and I
have shared this experience four times
at the commencement of each of our
children and so I know that you are
bursting with pride so let's celebrate
together let me ask the proud families
and friends of our graduates to join
those of us here on the stage to offer
warm congratulations to the yale college
class of 2011
now I would like to ask the class of
2011 in turn to reflect for just one
moment on how you came to reach this
milestone ok now that you've done that
one of the things that just might have
occurred to you during that moment of
reflection is that there are many people
here today your parents siblings
relatives and friends whose support and
encouragement made your achievements
here possible so why don't you rise now
and show them your appreciation
now let me elaborate on the
congratulations that we all just offered
you with our warm and heartfelt applause
You certainly have made something of
yourself here at Yale College first and
foremost you excelled in the classroom
tomorrow at the class day exercises when
you listen to the citations for those
winning academic prizes you will be
dazzled by their accomplishments but
it's not merely a few of you who have
excelled the cutoff grade point average
for the [ __ ] laude honors that are
awarded to thirty percent of you was the
highest in the history of Yale College
an amazing 3.78
you've excelled outside the classroom to
your artistic talent is stunning one of
you born of African parents and trained
in the classical repertoire has
revolutionized performance on the cello
creating a sound that seems like a
wreath of Franklin der Beyonce and he
learned Chinese along the way another a
junior Phi Beta Kappa majoring in the
history of art has starred in baroque
and classical opera while singing in
mixed company and women rhythm and yet
another has recorded ten songs with
between five and twenty six million
views on YouTube you've achieved
excellence in your athletic pursuits as
well this year Yale teams 17 Ivy League
championships for the first time in 21
years and only the fifth time ever
women's squash won the national title
and our men's hockey team thrilled us
all with their explosive play and their
number one seed in the NCAA tournament
you have explored the world 741 of you
have taken advantage of Yale's abundant
opportunities to learn languages take
courses conduct independent research or
work as interns in more than eighty four
countries around the globe and sixty
four of you have received fellowships
for overseas study next year
astonishingly more than 1000 of you have
demonstrated your commitment to service
by participating as volunteers in the
New Haven community you have tutored
school children engage them in science
fairs and service projects assisted in
the provision of care for those with
glaucoma and diabetes and raised funds
for the Boys and Girls Club of New Haven
you encouraged okay just last ago
you have encouraged the use of
sustainable products by departments of
the city government and campaign to make
New Haven more bicycle-friendly by
educating cyclists motorists and
pedestrians to share the streets safely
many of you have participated in a
flowering of entrepreneurship on the
campus ten of you one seed grants from
the Yale entrepreneurial Institute to
explore the possibility of starting
companies one of you started a recycling
business in science park that now has 30
fortune 500 companies among its clients
two of you found a rapidly growing
business for local online advertising
and yet another has already created 30
jobs in New Haven by founding the very
popular blue state coffeehouse which now
operates five retail stores in three
states some of you have overcome
tremendous obstacles to get here one of
you grew up in a chicago housing project
encouraged by her grandmother to avoid
the streets and read relentlessly she
won a scholarship to an outstanding
private school where she in turn was
encouraged to apply to Yale educated
poised and fearless she will return to
Chicago with Teach for America to a
charter school in an area much like her
old neighborhood to help others gain the
advantage that fear and for herself by
her hard work and determination
when I greeted you in this hall four
years ago I spoke about the lessons
taught in a book I had just read by
Anthony cron man sterling professor of
law and humanities and a former dean of
the Yale Law School professor chronons
central argument is that liberal
education should encourage you to
wrestle with the deepest questions
concerning the course of your lives what
constitutes a good life what kind of
life do you want to lead what values do
you hope to live by what kind of
community or society do you hope to live
in and how should you reconcile the
claims of family and community with your
individual desires in other words
professor chron Minh argues that an
important component of your
undergraduate experience should be
seeking answers to the questions that
matter over the past few months as many
of you have reflected upon what's next
as you leave Yale I imagine that some of
Professor chronons questions have been
on your mind some of you a minority I
suspect have found answers that satisfy
you and you are ready to pursue careers
that seem entirely right for you in
medicine or science or business or
teaching or public service the rest of
you most of you I'm sure are still
searching for answers some of you are
still searching for a job
so let me reassure you and your parents
this is fine really this is fine over
the next couple of years you will test
jobs or courses of study to see if they
truly lead you where you want to go you
will have a much happier life if you can
find a calling the truly excites and
inspires you so take your time and find
your passion and let me reassure you in
yet another way the work you choose in
the next few years need not limit your
ability to pursue other passions over
the course of your life yes we all hope
you'll find callings that you love but
one of the most remarkable things that I
have learned about Yale graduates is
their extraordinary ability to move from
one passion to another let me give you
an example two weeks ago I met with one
of our most devoted West Coast alumni a
graduate of the class of nineteen
fifty-five who has had a successful
career in business and finance and who
has been an important civic leader in
his community but his first love at Yale
was American history intrigued by
stories of the pioneers who settled the
American West and inspired by his mentor
the former dean of Yale College Howard
Lamar he decided a few years ago to take
on a truly ambitious piece of historical
and indeed archaeological research to
discover the route taken by the famous
lost lost wagon train that left the
Oregon Trail in 1845 to attempt a
shortcut across the desert of Eastern
Oregon many perished for want of water
and although several journals survive
and have served as the basis for a
number of historical monographs no one
has ever managed to find the exact route
taken by these pioneers the precise
location of the route is a particular
interest because according to the
journals that survived the pioneers
found gold nuggets in a dry riverbed
at the time water was more precious than
gold and so the settlers moved on
abandoning the site and marking it with
a blue bucket our intrepid banker
decided to find the route and he engaged
a geologist and archaeologists to museum
curators and aerial photographer and a
gold prospector equipped with metal
detectors to work with him using the
survivors Diaries he retraced the route
moving from one site to another on the
precise anniversary of the dates
recorded in the Diaries he found aerial
evidence of the route and many many
buried artifacts it took parts of five
years to complete the fieldwork now his
account of the root of the lost wagon
train is being reviewed for publication
by a major university press he is yet to
find the gold deposit but he thinks he
knows where it is this story is by no
means unique one member of the class of
nineteen fifty-three returned in midlife
to his passion for learning and founded
the Chicago humanities festival an
annual civic event that offers scores of
lectures and performances all over the
city a member of the class of nineteen
sixty-nine took up photography more than
25 years after graduating and he has
since published an extraordinary series
of books with the National Geographic
Society and a commodities trader from
the class of 1973 recently created a
brilliant tony-nominated Broadway
musical based on the life and work of a
great Nigerian musician singer and
songwriter and there are many more such
stories important as it is for you to
fulfill your personal admiration your
personal aspirations we truly hope you
will do this but there is also more
expected of you monday at commencement
exercises Dean Miller will ask me to
confer upon you
the degrees in Yale College that you
have earned in the curious tradition of
Yale College you will then inexplicably
cheer wildly and exuberantly even though
the Dean has only asked a question and
you have not yet graduated after you
settle down I will in fact confer upon
you your degrees but what I will say to
you differs significantly from what
college presidents all around the
country will be saying to their
graduates at many schools students are
awarded the rights and privileges of
their degrees not so at Yale here your
degrees will be conferred upon you and
you will be admitted to their rights and
responsibilities the rights are simple
enough you will be entitled to have an
alumni email address forever
you'll be entitled to vote in elections
for fellows of the Yale corporation
beginning five years from now you'll be
entitled to participate in a wide
variety of alumni events and interest
groups and to receive frequent
solicitations to support your alma mater
the rights conferred by other
institutions are much the same as yours
but what is distinctive about Yale is
that we do not confer upon you
privileges but admit you to
responsibilities now you've been here
for four years and I think you know what
I'm talking about for four years you
have been free to explore as you wish
but you have also been part of a
community you have learned not simply to
excel as individuals but also to support
and encourage one another to work in
organizations to accomplish common
purposes and to help those in need
through voluntary service the
citizenship and service that you have
modeled here at Yale has prepared you
for your lifelong responsibilities
whether working in community soup
kitchens or working at the highest
levels of government whether your
contributions are part-time or voluntary
our time and voluntary or at the core of
your chosen vocations you can make a
difference in the lives of others and
history gives me confidence that you
will all around this country Yale
graduates serve disproportionately on
the boards of local charities hospitals
civic and arts organizations Yale
graduates lead most of the major
environmental organization
in the United States and 9 of 100 US
senators and three of the last four
presidents of the United States of Yale
degrees the Yale tradition of service
and leadership is one of which we are
justly proud it is your responsibility
to maintain it women and men of the
class of 2011
today we celebrate your amazing
accomplishments and we rejoice in
contemplating your enormous potential
take the time to find your passion
choose a life's work that you love and
remember that the world is now your
community serve it well congratulations